I think that the respect of the first
two questions
it's quite interesting I think to define
what the differences are I mean I
personally don't think for example the
desire to elect your government is a
kind of western value you know my view
is pretty much when people get the
chance it's what they prefer to do now
some countries need to evolve to that
state because of their development and
so on and you know simply you know if
you've got a country that's under
essentially a process of evolutionary
development if you take China for
example there will be a political
evolution that will take time it's not
just going to happen overnight and
that's sensible actually in order to
keep the stability of the country but
you know I think when you analyze you
know what is the difference in values
and what are the difference you know to
refer to Alex's question the different
governments have about the proper place
of religion in the public sphere I think
you can come to certain common rules
reasonably quickly actually unless what
you have is a view that is probably one
part of a religious face view as to what
those proper values are in other words
let me know again specific if you take
the role of women in society or in
politics now you will find there are
people who will say within Islam for
example that the role of women are
secondary to our men that they don't
agree with gender equality and so on and
so forth on the other hand actually you
will find many people that do articulate
those values and there is often a battle
going on within the faith about you know
what the faith means for for certain
policies and so I think the thing that
we need to explore is the degree to
which the values actually are
fundamentally different and the degree
to which it suits the purpose of certain
people often for political reasons to
say that they are very different see
what I mean so in other words I think
that you know there are various cultural
things that are going to be different
there are various practices that will be
different but actually when you really
look at basic values do you treat people
equally should there be just systems of
law should free speech be allowed and so
on actually what you find is I think is
that you will get certain countries that
will say well we are not ready for that
process of evolution yet and that's a
thing you can partner as it were you two
there's a relationship you can have
around that because they're saying look
yes I understand where there's a there's
a timeline here that we need to follow
in our development but then you get
people who are actually intrinsically
hostile to those very concepts and
that's a different a different matter
but I think you find that those that are
intrinsically hostile are a much
narrower group and the one thing I don't
think we should ever allow is for
certain people to define what the values
of their civilization or their culture
are when actually they don't necessarily
represent the entirety of the view
within that faithful or culture so I I
think what we try and do is we try and
achieve as much common space as possible
that's really what I'm saying and we do
that acknowledging that references will
be genuinely cultural but actually a lot
more maybe to do with politics and you
will find people from within the same
culture who take the same view as we do